Yes, I'm Paula Braun.
I'm an entrepreneur in residence with
the National Center for Health Statistics at
the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention.
I'm Ryan Hoffman. I am a PhD student
in Biomedical Engineering in Dr. May Kwong's lab at Georgia Tech.
Yes. So, the clinical decision support tool that we're developing,
is specifically designed to help
physicians collect more complete and accurate information on
death certificates and to send that information to the state where the death occurred.
And what makes death reporting challenging is that,
the clinician is required to make a decision
about the sequence of events that led to death.
Typically, it's somewhat more clear to understand the immediate cause of death,
but to provide enough information on the death certificate
to ascertain the underlying cause,
can be quite of challenge.
However, there's ample information in
some circumstances in the electronic medical record.
And so, the tool that we've developed is designed specifically to try to fetch
that data and to put it in a easily interpretable display so that way,
the clinician isn't combing through
multiple tabs and spending a lot of time trying to figure out,
what is this patient's health history?
And it goes a step further where it's not just
about displaying information that's in the medical record,
but ultimately connecting to an external analytical engine that applies
more advanced analytics to return recommendations
about probable sequences of events that may have led to death.
Absolutely. So here you can see the main interface,
the main screen of our cause of death reporting prototype app.
The main feature of the app is this timeline right here in the middle.
We wanted to be able to show not just the immediate proximate causes of death,
but also add some context for the clinician.
The whole point of this app was to let us bring in all the information possible,
give the clinician the clearest picture that we could.
So, what we've done with this timeline is,
we've used a kind of logarithmic scaling so that we can show
the immediate causes and the deeper patient history all in one glance.
All of the conditions on this timeline were pulled out of the medical record using FHIR
and we filtered them based on a list of valid reportable mortality conditions,
try to limit the noise and make this just as useful as we can.
So beneath the main timeline where you see the extracted conditions laid out,
there are also these orange timelines.
What these are, are the results of the analytic system that Paula was talking about.
What they are, are the proposals for possible causal pathways which
might link these conditions into a chain of events that could possibly lead to death.
When the clinician needs to change,
modify, or add any causes of death,
we have an area down at the bottom of the screen that's designed to
resemble the death certificate that they are already familiar with.
Here, they can change any of the condition names,
correct any of the timeline issues,
and add new conditions if they need to.
These controls down here,
then allow the clinician to save this data
back to the medical record and complete the process.
Certainly. One of the first data sets that the students analyzed was an ontology which
is a list of known causal pathways that CDC provided to the students.
And these relationships were developed by
the National Center for Health Statistics and
other statistical agencies across the country and
they're commonly used as part of the automated coding system for trying to
assign an international classification of disease code
to underlying causes of death and contributing causes of death.
That data set is important because the space that it traverses is quite large.
And so, the challenge of mapping out the network and
trying to understand how you can move from one node on the network to another,
was quite computationally extensive.
Another data set that we're analyzing,
is the public use data set.
So the National Center for Health Statistics aggregates information
from death certificates that are collected across the country.
And what we have there is,
we have an ICD-10 coded representation of
what the physicians wrote on the death certificates.
So we've begun to apply various causal modeling actually.
So we have the information that
physicians actually put on death certificates and what we're beginning to do there,
is to look at what are the associations that most commonly occur.
And from that, we're beginning to get a much more nuanced understanding of,
what are the proper associations that
physicians are reporting on death certificates and where are
the areas where physicians may be putting things
in a sequence that's not actually ideologically sound.
And so, it's been very much
a learning process for us to be able to look at our data in this way.
And the third and perhaps the most exciting source of data that we're
analyzing in the process of building this analytical engine is that,
we've partnered with two of our states and they've provided
link data between the hospital discharge record and the death certificate record.
And this is where the students are really beginning to apply
deep learning methods to not only uncover associations,
but ultimately, causal pathways that then could be fed
back to the physician at the time that the physician is certifying the death certificate.
So in designing the prototype application,
the two most important data sets to me,
were the ontology containing all of
the valid causal relations between possible causes of death,
and the NCHS multiple causes of death data.
The public data that Paula was talking.
We use the ontology to filter down the conditions that we show in
the timeline to limit noise and make the interface more useful to the clinician.
We use sequential pattern mining algorithms to identify
common temporal links between causes of death in the public causes of death data.
And that was what we used in the prototype application,
to propose possible linkages between one cause of death and another.
Basically, to try and give the clinician a sense of how
these might tie together in a likely way.
And what's so exciting about the modularity of FHIR is that,
the app that Ryan is developing and the team is developing,
we could start with a simple analytical engine and
exchange it as the understanding becomes more evolved.
And over time, we're hoping that we'll have more people
that are contributing to these analytical engines so that way,
we can provide the physician the most and the best information at
the time that they're certifying the death.
Absolutely. So we designed the application to use SMART on FHIR.
It's a very traditional client based SMART on FHIR Javascript app,
that connects to the HR,
pulls these conditions out,
and does the filtering and display activities that I've talked about.
But, we also have it designed so that it can modularly be integrated with
additional outside servers to
provide additional services and additional functionality to the app.
Most interesting, are connections to the O-Methylisourea which we're using to
prototype code crosswalk to
try and make everything a little bit more compatible with our rule mining system,
and the actual rule mining analytics system.
We used a relatively simple,
sequential pattern mining technique for the initial prototype application,
but that is designed to be completely modular.
We want to be able to iterate on those algorithms over time,
improve them with use.
Well, Ryan and the team are taking the next step which is to
work with one of
the major electronic medical record vendors
on their SMART on FHIR app platform that they're offering.
And we have jurisdictions across the country that are
excited and lining up to test out the first phase of it.
That first part, will most likely not incorporate the analytical engine just so we
can learn the environment and get
some real world feedback before doing further development.
Thank you.